no if you ever wanted to know what a
full-blown shutdown looks like Ryan
Reynolds is here with the master class
no ok let's rewind it all started when
Tom Holland wowed the internet with this
yeah that's the 23 year old multitasking
like a boss putting a shirt on while
doing a handstand Tom shared the clip on
his instace story and challenged ryan
and jake gyllenhaal to give it a go
enter Orion with the note to end all
knows Ryan shared that clip on his
instace Tori staring at the camera
looking hella confused before dropping a
hard no on Tom Tom got a kick out of
Ryan's reaction and shared it to his own
insta story along with three crying
laughing emojis and while the Deadpool
star may not have completed the
shirtless handstand challenge Jake did
[Music]
I would like to take a second to thank
Tom for prompting this glorious
shirtless moment thank you Tom
truly thank you anyway Jake posted the
video to his Instagram story declaring
challenge accepted Tom shared the clip
gushing yes mate you hero and Jake
passed the challenge along to his sister
Maggie Gyllenhaal as well as Hugh
Jackman and 50 cent no but back to Ryan
we are doing a lot of homeschooling
we're doing uh we're lucky enough to
have a little tiny garden so we're
learning a little bit about gardening
we're trying to make us an educational
experience but I'm mostly drinking Ryan
was a whole damn mood during a chat with
Stephen Colbert on The Late Show
Wednesday revealing how he and his wife
Blake Lively along with their three
daughters are social distancing amid the
ongoing coronavirus outbreak
I do not miss masculine company at all
really most most you know men tend to
just be the architects of someone's
demise so it's fine I like just being
here with the girls I like doing the
girls stuff I like you know like I try
not to push sort of gender normative
ideas on my kids as they're born but
each one when they came out that shoot
they were just they really wanted to
make dresses they wanted to dress in hot
pink all day so that's what I do as for
Blake she's making sure Ryan keeps it
looking fresh even if they are locked up
at the house tomorrow
Blake is gonna who's gonna give me a
haircut she's done this once before yeah
it took two and a half hours and and
then at the end it looked like she'd
done the whole thing using only a
lighter or like or like those you know
those gloves that are made of sandpaper
it would have been a little faster
Murphy she just wore it down but she
just rubs my head until the hair just
disappeared so tomorrow we're gonna I'm
getting a haircut very exciting you have
fun we're best friends and the two are
doing their best to give back in a big
way Ryan and Blake have donated 1
million dollars to food banks in Canada
and the US as well as $400,000 to New
York City hospitals and Ryan's gin Label
AV
chené also pledged a percentage of sales
to help out-of-work bartenders who have
been hit hard by the social distancing
guidelines I'm not really in the
business of telling people what to do
necessarily but I do think it's
incumbent upon you know those who who
can get back to do so
[Music]